my name is Emmanuel and I work for
warfront association team I'm a totally
way about Geographic Association so I'm
essentially going to show of new
functions for visualization of
geographical data and then we are going
to compare how different data can be
visualized in different ways by using
the functions for geography
crystallization
my name is Emily Garces and I work for
the Welfare Association Tim and today
I'm going to talk about we call it a
deal for surety right right what is a
geographic Association functions so the
overview of the talk is to give a very
brief introduction to yo graphics as a
function then I will introduce a new
function in version 11.3 called the
smooth history then after introducing
this function I'm going to compare how
same data can be visualized by using
different visualization functions that
that we already have after that I'm
going to focus on particular futures
features of those visualization
functions and the last thing I'm going
to talk about is new functions that are
going to be in version 12 okay so as
probably many of you know we have a
Geographics function that allow us to
show maps we can fill that function with
cities countries or any other place in
the world by giving some ranges so there
is no limit for specifying what we want
to just show geographies have different
options one of them is uske baare as you
can see there is a little bar here
showing us the city the distance or the
proportion of the map according to miles
of kilometers we can say show geo grid
lines according to angles or probably
distances
your range in this example we are
showing just one point but the gear
range giving in this example is a
country this case is a USA we can feed
geography squid Java backgrounds we have
different settings or background I'm
just showing four of them here we can
change the geo projection in this case I
am Li showing for ya but we have many
many of them there are different kinds
of geo projections right so we also have
primitives there are several of them I
only showing four we can highlight a
polygon we can put geo markers in the
map we could put your circles by setting
what is the radius of the circle we want
to show we have things like showing what
is the part of the world with night day
we have some others but I'm only showing
some of them in order to let you know
what can be don't win with geographic
straight so we have we have like five or
four functions that allow us to show
data to that map the new one in version
11 point three is called use mood
histogram probably many of you have
heard about geo historian that is a
discrete version of this new function
the old one
show us there we have a set of points
and we want to know how many of them
are falling into some bins in this case
the default being shape is a hexagon so
in this example we have the cities of
Island right so in this case in this
area we have just four so this is a
histogram for four four maps we have
points in in the maps and we show the
histogram but we also can can plot you
can use histogram for showing regions
with positions associated with values in
this example we have the largest cities
of USA associated with their population
for instance in this area we have this
number of populations right of course
this is near New York and this is Los
Angeles Awana so we here we are showing
how many people we have there so we have
two different ways of use geo historian
but now with the same data we are using
the new function you it smooth histogram
and this allows us to see the same
distribution but in a smoother version
so we are he here we are using a plot of
the PDF based on smooth kernel estimate
from the same data so this is the same
example we saw before for the cities in
in Iceland and this is the same example
for the population of the largest cities
of the USA but using this new function
right ok as we are using smooth kernel
estimate we have parameters for
for this so one of them is the runs
which in this example I'm just showing
two of them but there are more methods
so I'm showing those two because those
are looks very different right so as you
know that the bank would determines like
the area covered by the intensity plot
another parameter for for this PDF is
the kernel method we also have the read
of them but I'm just showing two of them
because they look different so you can
try it with different methods by the way
this is the symbolic interpretation for
geo positions so you can use different
kind of input but in this case I'm just
using this object as input data okay
there are many options for it geo smooth
histogram you can fix I mean you can mix
different options coming from
Geographics and also coming for smooth
density histogram so as you can see the
four examples at the top are options for
Geographic and the four options below
are coming from smooth density history
so you can mix both options and see
interesting results okay and as
application example we have
in this in this data the positions of
registered risk here in Champaign and
then we are showing here you smooth
histogram of those positions so as you
can see this is a map of champagne you
can see the red areas are almost the
same right as a matter of fact when I
was flying for I come from Mexico so
when I was flying new champagne I saw
very similar distribution of of the
trees so it's interesting this example
okay this is the new function for eleven
point three now that we have that
function we can compare different
functions by using the same data so in
this case the data is the position of
the European countries if we use the
oldest plot we get this this image that
it's not that interesting because the
oldest plot only shows the real world
their points are located if we use new
histogram with the same data as you can
see then we are showing the number of
countries that are inside every in every
bean so for instance this in this bin
lived three countries right but if we
use the new function G histogram we get
similar distribution
but in a smoother smoother version okay
what happened if I use an array of
coordinates as this culinary array of
coordinates and we use the same
philosophy that we use in the example
before we have a random set of points
now I'm using random your position as
you remember this trace different
introduce this function that allows to I
[Music]
mean generates homogeneous set of points
for a given area right in this case we
are giving asada 300 random points of
the world and the same thing happened if
we use the list plot we are your theory
the point if you use your histogram we
are showing the points in the ravine in
this case what you know this is really
nice but there are only 300 maybe we use
you know ten thousand that will look
like that but if we now use you
histogram we get smoother version of
this one so this is a discrete version
and this is the continuous version let's
say okay another example of same data
shown by different functions is new
entities associate
with some values now those values can be
numeric or it can be quantities this
example I'm showing the okay we have the
population all of the Americas country
so if we use view nutrient value plot we
are showing with colors the quantity of
the number of population of each country
so as you can see USA and Brazil have
more population and so no so on
according to to these orders but now we
can use your bubble chart because the
geo bubble chart also uses relations
between positions and values but in this
case
Yahoo chart uses bubbles and their sizes
are proportional to the total quantities
or the values we can use also you
histogram because you history can also
be paired with you know positions and
values so in this case the USA in this
area we have this number of of
populations and so on but we can use the
smooth histogram as you can see there
are people in this area right in this
point okay so it's the same data but we
are using different we saw such a
functions now another example is
entities associated to quantities this
example we have some counties for some
US states the value is the per capita
income
if it's County so we also use get
rubella plot we can use the bubble chart
but this is not very interesting because
almost each county has the same income
but the interesting thing here is that
as we have many counties here so the
income is more in this in this part of
the of the country right and it look
like the same as just not history okay
well we can use as a seated map that I
also shows the same this case is a
population of the rope and countries ok
let's continue some particular features
of missiles in your functions is that
your list plot can plot set of groups of
entities so for instance if we group
those then we have different scholars
like that's a property of your list plot
the history and also supports different
bins not only hexagons
it supports rectangles triangles in this
case we have it depends of the area
right we have 1000 degrees or we can
define for example school district in
this case we here we have one entity
when what point in this school district
entity so what right wall chart has
ability to show bubbles according to the
their data for instance this is a map of
the area of which stay
state of the USA and the blue area is
showing us different area of each one so
we are using pie charts
instead of bubbles the new functions for
question 12 are G vector plot and Justin
plot given to plot essentially it takes
as input geo vector object tomorrow Jose
at 2:00 p.m. in the same room is going
to talk about the structure of the
vector but as you can see we can plot
vectors a vector field a stream lines
coming form that vector field so they
inputted the same okay these two new
functions except also an object called G
vector E and you okay let me explain
quickly G vector itself is set of
vectors and each one of them contains a
modulus of the vector and I will ring
the a direction right but we can also
define a vector not just as modulus and
a direction but we can define a vector
as north and east component even an op
component that's where they used and for
that's east not up but in this case
where you just using is a north but
possibly the future for example for my
negative magnetic vectors where we can
use the up edge
okay
we can also use quantity really as you
can see there are different combinations
of inputs but I am Li showing three of
them because there is not really big
time for that now options in this case
as the vector plot is choosing let's say
is almost the same like least better
plot and Geographics then we can mix
options from media graphics please
better plot so as you can see we can use
your background for instance we can use
the Richter scale with the color
function and so on right remember that
vector markers as if any of you attended
bred stock he told us about this a
vector markers option so in this case
I'm using the dart leg to the right so
let's see the options for stream plot I
mean just in plot it's almost the same
case for the Elector plot you can use
options for listing plot and Geographics
but in this case for instance we don't
have a vector style we have stream style
we have stream color function we have
stream color and portion scaling and so
on so we we also have stream markers in
this case I'm using a different stream
address okay now what can what can we do
with this right
it's an application I remember when they
sure came Florence I collected some
later form from our own databases wind
data then I collected an information and
I was able to produce this plot okay so
that one application for director plot
as you can see didn't talk about this
option this is showing us only the
depart of the vectors for the u.s. area
so we are not not showing vectors at the
ocean right so we can really limit the
freedom we can show the the vectors
another application for stream plot I'm
using the magnetic model data so this is
the streamlines of the as I said the the
magnetic vectors at the North Pole
so it's reinter listing how you can see
every stream is pointing to their so
they know a magnetic north pole right
and there are five seconds left so you
finish time okay thank you very much
you